we're gonna talk about primitive
functions now underneath you what I want
to do is um leave a space underneath you
maybe a couple of lines and then after a
couple of lines I'd like you to write f
of X okay
in calculus we've been talking about
functions that's kind of our main object
and we apply the process of
differentiation to a function when you
differentiate when you differentiate the
only thing you get out of that goes by a
couple of different names at least what
kinds of names would you call it you
differentiate it and the result is the
we could call the gradient function the
gradient function that's why this is
useful I'm gonna write that down in a
second we would also call it like one
word the starts of the day the
derivative or I'm gonna write that down
so we call this the derivative and in
this scheme we would notate it as f dash
we call the derivative because it comes
from the function that you're interested
in right so derivatives or of course the
gradient function they tell us something
about the original function and how it
behaves or how it looks like okay now
it's therefore not that much a stretch
of the imagination to imagine well what
if this function itself was a derivative
you know maybe this is like a first
derivative and this is a second root
that means it also came from something
before it does that make sense there's
like an extra letter that's why I asked
you to put a couple of them empty things
now if you put the arrow up right from f
of X you can get F dash right but where
did F X come from is a few different
ways to imitate this but the most common
way in this game is with a capital F
okay you can read this in a couple of
different ways like this is f dash this
is sometimes called F prime but the most
common name is that it's called the
primitive function
Prime primitive you get the idea you can
see derivative means okay what do you
get out of this primitive means where
did you come from like primitive human
species and that kind of thing okay now
in here what is the process by which we
get up to this okay now please note some
of you have learnt ahead and you might
think you know what belongs here what
word belongs here we'll be very careful
with this and very deliberate in this
scheme in this context with the
knowledge that we have now because what
we're doing is the opposite of
differentiation the opposite of
differentiation this process is properly
named anti-differentiation as it were
you're undoing the process of
differentiation right if I were to
differentiate F Prime if I were to
differentiate the primitive U and land
on this function the one that we started
with okay anti differentiation is what
it's called
we'll come to the other names that that
process might get to when it's the right
time okay now here's the weird thing
this is all abstract okay we want some
actual examples of what's going on so in
parallel to this let's just come up with
an example a simple one like say x
squared okay now we know what happens
when we differentiate if we
differentiate this then of course the
derivative of x squared is 2x oh good
now think about this when you
differentiate what you're doing is you
bring the power down and you reduce the
power by one so being that we try to
undo this we're trying to
anti-differentiate if I think about or I
where did this come from what was it
that got differentiated to become x
squared I have to do the reverse of that
now please note let's actually write
this down okay
the rule that makes this work in our
head is bring power
down make up a coefficient right and
then reduce the power by one okay so
when we do this anti differentiation
process we have to do this exact thing
but everything is backwards everything
is backwards so there's a step one step
two right do you notice when we
differentiate you have to do it in this
order you can't reduce the power first
and then bring it down because that's
not the derivative okay so I had to do
this order differently so I'm gonna do
this step first but I'm also going to do
it in Reverse so instead of reducing the
power I'm going to increase the power
right so that's the first thing I do I'm
going to increase power by one okay and
then now I'm coming to this so instead
of bringing the power down right which
is in a sense multiplying by that power
what am I going to do here what's the
opposite of multiplying dividing right
in fact a better way it's just so
colloquial that we're very comfortable
er a better way to say bring power down
is multiplied by the power here we're
dividing by the power does that make
sense
okay let's do it the power is currently
two so when I increase it you're going
to get three that's the first step now
I'm going to divide by this new power
which gives me at that now one of my
favorite things about this part of
mathematics is that it's so easy to
confirm just like solving an equation
did I get it right because of course if
I ante differentiated correctly then
differentiation should me bring me back
to here let's just quickly see if it
works
multiply by the power which gives you 3x
cubed on 3 so the 3s will cancel that's
good and then reduce the power by 1
which comes to 2 thumbs up it worked
okay ah but here's the weird part and
here is why my title and your title has
a plural in it ok functions have
derivatives one function has one
derivative and only one like this has to
be the answer right there's no other
Jews that it constantly made but when it
comes to primitives there are actually
many other things that we could have
started from that when you're different
share will still land you on x-squared
think about this right if I had
something up here like say X cubed on 3
that stuff is all still the same and if
I had something over here that when I
differentiated it didn't add anything or
subtracted it didn't change anything
you'd still end up with x squared
weren't you well what might be something
else we could have there plus 5 why not
you differentiate that add 0 no big deal
or in the same way I could say X cubed
on 3 I could subtract something right
subtract anything you like something
weird all right it's still going to
differentiate and come out in the wash
you still will end up with x squared ok
so what you're creating up here maybe
you want to put this in another color or
something like that what I've got up
here and it's this there's many more
right what I have up here is what we
call the family of primitive
it's a family they all share the same
DNA but they can't be different okay now
because I've just got examples here
right I'd much prefer to actually
generalize this a little bit I can add
or subtract any number I like and we'll
still be in the family okay so therefore
what we say is well if you're adding or
subtracting any constant you like let's
just give the constant name constant
constant what would be a good letter to
denote a constant well it's interesting
I mean we choose sometimes completely
nonsensical letters but whatever I
thankfully here it makes sense we use
the letter C for the constant so we
would say that everything in this family
approved functions is of the form
wrong color is all the form X cubed on 3
plus C okay so that constant can be
whatever anything you want let's label
that accordingly
okay now underneath here and with this
we use this example let's just quickly
draw what this might look like okay
executes on three if was just X cubed
because on three is just a change of
scale right what does X cube look like
don't you describe that what kind of
features does it have that you know
about X cubes is a point of inflection
and it's not just any point inflection
it's a horizontal point of inflection so
let's go ahead and let's draw it if I
put some coordinates for scale then that
would make it execute on three now what
would these guys look like in terms of
how they look different to this well the
X cubed on 3 plus 5 where's that in
relation to this it's just been shifted
vertically soon translated ok so I can
draw the same thing just higher like so
and that would just be 5 there
what about the other one execute on 3
minus PI it's the same thing but lower
ok so I'm just going to draw the same
agreement under here and I guess that
would make that negative PI because
that's weird all right so why is this
whole family going to end up at the same
thing well if I would you take any spot
let's see how well
drawn this I don't know maybe quite
badly if I want to take any spot on this
curve pick an x value any x value x
equals 1 for instance if you have a look
at all those spots for x equals 1 here
here and here at each of those spots if
my drawing is reasonable the tangents
will all be parallel do you agree if the
tangents are all parallel that means the
gradients are the same because they all
have the same grain function does this
make sense it doesn't matter how far up
or down you are you're going to get the
same gradient all of these things belong
in the same family does that make sense
so for now this is the end of this topic
that we know how to differentiate but we
also know how to come to come back to
where did you where did this come from
right what was the proof that preceded
this ok if you are ever asked for the
primitive function for this you would
say X cubed on 3 plus C how about just
to make sure you don't get away with my
sneaky how about something like this oh
yeah just for the secular what's this
thing gonna be what function did this
come from well I know how to
differentiate it to anti-differentiate
under everything in Reverse let's go one
at a time tell me that's right
3 X ^ you've increased the power by 1
and then what do you do with that new
power you got to divide by that 6 that's
going to end up on the denominator yes
so far so good alright this guy think
because this is an X to the 0 term isn't
it so you're going to increase that
power by 1 which gives you X to the
power of 1 and then you're going to
divide by that new power right of course
I can tighten this up a little bit this
of course will be well let's say that's
going to give you 2 so X to the 6 on 4
plus 31 X that's only one of the
primitives right that's one possible
premium so how do I turn this into the
premium
function this constant right aha now
I've covered myself this could be
anything does that make sense okay